alors on a dit que c'était le carré VIP
il y a pas de carré VIP les Baumettes
c'est pourri non il y a pas de carrière
et puis du tout
on nous accueillons notre terrien du
samedi 20h ce soir sous les mêmes
Diawara bonsoir
alors Souleymane sous les
joueurs emblématique de l'OM vous êtes
retrouvé en avril dernier derrière les
barreaux de la prison des Baumettes
pourquoi comment avec quelles
conséquences sur votre carrière vous
nous raconterez votre histoire à 20h
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sous les manne Diawara rebonsoir
vous êtes né le 24 décembre
1978 à Gabou au Sénégal votre père était
ouvrier chez Goodyear et votre mère
femme au foyer 11 enfants
quand la famille Diawara arrive en
France vous n'avez pas encore deux ans
et vous installez au Havre dans le
quartier de Caucriauville dans une tour
HLM alors sous Pompidou coquille comme
vous dites était classé ZUP faire zone à
urbanisée en priorité après c'est devenu
une zette une zone d'éducation
prioritaire et encore après une ZUS dire
une zone urbaine sensible c'est la la
chute à coqueries tous les jeunes jouent
au foot c'est ça dans un club qui
s'appelle le Sporting Club de frileuse
mon frère joue tous dans ce club et un
jour Salif l'aîné est appelé pour
intégrer le centre de formation du Havre
mais votre père refuse il lui dit
d'aller bosser chez Renault
je pense qu'il savait pas qu'il y avait
autant d'argent il pensait qu'à Renault
on gagne beaucoup plus d'argent et quand
la première fois mon grand frère est
arrivé avec le contrat professionnel il
a vu les sommes d'argent ouais il va
dire mon autre grand frère Salif
d'arrêter et travailler chez Renault
pour aller chez pour rentrer au centre
de formation malheureusement c'était
trop tard effectivement quand vient le
tour de Djibril votre père accepte parce
qu'il découvre les fiches de paie de
Monaco de Turin ou de Bolton et là il
comprend effectivement qu'il vaut mieux
aller faire du sport Faire du foot que
d'aller chez Renault alors vous avez un
copain qui s'appelle même Adou Niang
évidemment qui est devenu lui aussi un
très grand footballeur notamment à l'OM
et quand il intègre le centre de
formation vous voulez le suivre sauf que
vous mettez du temps pour y arriver ils
vous prennent pas tout de suite
mon frère mon grand frère Salif
qui qui avions moi des qualités et qui
étaient sûrs de mes qualités et aller
voir
Jean-Marc nobulot c'était le nouvel
entraîneur du centre de formation il est
allé le voir il lui a dit j'ai un frère
d'énormes qualités je pense qu'il peut
faire quelque chose et au bout du
quatrième essai c'est là qui m'a accepté
en arrivant au Havre athlétique club
vous jouez en attaque et c'est Jean-Marc
Nobilo donc il vous met derrière et là
vous faites la gueule vous voulez pas
aller derrière bah ouais quand on joue
au foot c'est pour marquer c'est mieux
de marquer que de défendre mais bon à
ses yeux j'étais pas du tout en
attaquant on m'a vu grand costaud un
petit bourrin quoi il avait eu du flair
Nobilo je vous remercie maintenant
alors un an et demi après vous intégrez
l'équipe pro qui joue en Ligue 1 et en
janvier 2000 contre l'OM vous devenez le
joueur au gant noir à l'époque j'avais
une bague que ma maman m'avait offert et
je voulais pas la quitter cette vague
parce que vous portez voilà et
à l'époque on avait pas le droit de
jouer avec les banques enfin même encore
donc la seule solution que j'avais
trouvée c'était de jouer avec des gants
et
à partir
de là j'ai commencé à jouer alors après
cinq ans au Havre ce show vous appelle
vous y allez là vous décrocher votre
premier trophée la Coupe de la Ligue en
août 2006 le Charlton athlétique de
Londres vous achète
5,5 millions d'euros
là vous découvrez le championnat anglais
la hargne la rage de gagner je suis
arrivé dans un autre monde vraiment à
part où que ce soit l'entraînement en
match toujours gagné gagner même les
petits jeux pour rigoler ils veulent pas
ils veulent pas perdre ils veulent
jamais perdre et c'est vrai que c'est
quand je suis arrivé là-bas j'ai
beaucoup appris grâce à ce club ensuite
c'est Bordeaux la deuxième année à
Bordeaux c'est l'apothéose les Girondins
décrochent la Coupe de la Ligue et le
championnat de France et là vous
découvrez la vie de champion alors vous
dites tu payes plus rien tu es invité
partout c'est la folie c'est le kiffe
c'est un kiffe quand bien sûr on a la
chance de d'être champion de France et
c'est vrai que c'était l'apothéose
Laurent Blanc
alors à la fin de la saison
Bordeaux ne veut pas vous augmenter
c'était déjà Nicolas taverno le patron
des Girondins c'est ça oui c'est pour ça
Nicolas si tu nous regardes la Marseille
vous propose deux fois plus y aller ça
se refuse pas et cette année là
Marseille explose Coupe de la Ligue
d'abord vous marquez le premier des
trois buts de la finale contre les
Girondins
bonjour
et quelques semaines plus tard l'OM est
sacré champion de France
et là c'est la là c'est la folie m'a
fait rêver c'est cool bah ouais c'est
bien de le voir maintenant
regarde ça il dit j'avais l'impression
que la France entière était là c'est à
dire que il y avait tout le monde quoi
c'était vraiment un grand moment
c'était vraiment la folie à Marseille
déjà qu'on avait gagné la première Coupe
de la Ligue
c'était le feu et je me souviens que
Josiane et Go me disait que si on gagne
le titre ça va être multiplié par 10 et
là on le voit encore les gens de toute
la France
à nouveau la Coupe de la Ligue c'est la
quatrième fois pour vous je crois que
c'est le record c'est énorme moi c'est
pas mal
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais là c'est le bras
[Musique]
durant l'été 2012 sur une plage privée à
Saint-Tropez vous faites la connaissance
sous les d'un mec sympa ancien
légionnaire devenu garagiste et il vous
entend dire que vous cherchez une Rover
donc il vous propose de vous aider vous
devenez assez proche de lui vous
rencontrez sa femme ses gosses vous
appelez tous les jours des liens sont
créés entre le et moi et sa famille
aussi
mais
je n'ai vu que du feu on va dire oui
vous dit bon je vais t'en trouver une
Gigi vous lui donnez 50000 pour qu'il
achète la caisse le problème c'est que
la Range Rover Tarz va arriver
mais ça vous inquiète pas plus que ça
finalement vous dites pas arrivé la
bagnole c'est vrai que l'ami enfin j'ai
attendu trois ans puisque
même plus parce qu'elle est même pas là
encore donc
à partir de là bon tout ce qu'on va dire
maintenant c'est votre version n'est
fait puisque pas une procès etc début
faute de Range Rover le garagiste lui
dit bah écoute la reine c'est difficile
je te propose une Porsche Cayenne il
vous dit d'aller chercher le la voiture
donc la Porsche Cayenne en région
parisienne c'est ça et en faisant les
papiers vous découvrez qu'il s'agit
d'une voiture volée qui a été replacée
en fait il m'avait proposé de en
attendant le Range que j'avais commandé
qui me prêtait le Porsche Cayenne en
échange de 10000 euros au départ je veux
pas de Porsche Cayenne moi je veux mon
Range Rover et bon je commence à me
gratter la tête je me dis
en fait cette voiture je crois que j'ai
jamais la revoir
donc j'accepte de
prendre le Cayenne
et au moment d'aller faire les papiers
j'appelle mon mon collègue qui travaille
à la police je lui ai demandé tu peux me
donner les renseignement sur cette
voiture et c'est là qu'il me dit que
cette voiture elle est gagée elle est
elle est voler c'est une doubler ne
roule plus avec tu peux avoir des gros
problèmes et là donc vous appelez le
garagiste il a pu l'argent
et un jour il vous répond plus il vous
prend plus au téléphone et là
[Musique]
j'ai tranquille va y avoir du sport même
moi vous dites à votre petit frère Adama
d'aller chez lui pour récupérer le
pognon il y va avec quatre potes et en
arrivant il prend son téléphone il est
là avec le garagiste il le met sur
haut-parleur et là le garagiste c'est
pas grave écoute attends une semaine on
va s'arranger vous dites-moi une caisse
en attendant et quand même Adama et ses
potes repartent avec une BMW Série 7 on
est d'accord
mais le garagiste c'est incroyable porte
plainte pour extorsion de fond le 8
avril dernier les gendarmes vous
interpellent au petit matin à
Cagnes-sur-Mer
je dormais à la maison
j'arrive à 6h du matin
mon petit frère il se réveille le
premier il me dit il y a les gendarmes
pourquoi
donc j'arrive j'ouvre la porte oui mon
monsieur
à compter de ces torciers vous êtes en
garde à vue je lui demande pourquoi des
tentatives d'extorsion j'ai commencé à
tentative d'extorsion
vous avez été demandé de l'argent à
monsieur
en question
j'étais non j'ai pas été demandé de
l'argent j'ai été demandé mon argent que
mon argent donc à partir de là
mise en examen vous retrouvez au
Beaumettes alors qu'en fait il y avait
pas eu de coups portés contre ce
garagiste votre frère il est pas arrivé
avec un flingue je veux dire bon il y a
pas eu d'interruption temporaire de
travail pour le garagiste il y a rien eu
il y a rien eu bon vous retrouver au net
alors tout le monde pense que vous allez
sortir très vite ils vont mettre à
l'isolement
alors on a dit que c'était le carré VIP
il y a pas de carré VIP les Baumettes
c'est pourri non il y a pas de carrière
et puis du tout
non non c'était l'isolement après ils
m'ont dit ils m'ont mis là-bas pour
raison de sécurité
étant entre guillemets une célébrité en
plus ancien joueur de l'OM et la voyage
que les femmes de l'OM et Mamadou Niang
n'a même pas le droit de venir vous voir
au parloir non c'est comme si vous étiez
un dangereux criminel quand même on va
dire ça
le 12 juin dernier vous faites une
demande de remise en liberté elle est
refusée pour quelle raison
je ne sais pas non
plus libéré quand même le 26 juin 2015
j'ai fait quand même 11 semaines de
détention le Scorpion
et surtout vous avez perdu votre contrat
avec l'ogcnisme parce que eux ils ont
commencé la saison ils se débrouillent
plutôt bien d'ailleurs faut reconnaître
très bien très bien et là vous avez plus
de boulot alors non
mais alors aujourd'hui vous avez quoi
comme bagnole
une voiture sans permis
[Rires]
maintenant cinéma
je suis sûr vous allez faire du cinéma
moi j'ai trouvé un rôle un mec qui se
fait arnaquer par un garagiste
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
Inna larditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu